we're told carbon 14 is an element which
loses exactly half of its mass every 5
730 years
the mass of a sample of carbon 14 can be
modeled by a function m which depends on
its age t in years
we measure that we measure that the
initial mass of a sample of carbon 14 is
741 grams
write a function that models the mass of
the carbon-14 sample remaining t years
since the initial measurement
all right so like always pause the video
and see if you can come up with this
function m that is going to be a
function of t the the the years since
the initial measurement
all right let's work through it together
what i like to do is i always like to
start up with a little bit of a table to
get a sense of things
so let's think about t
how much time how many years have passed
since the initial measurement and
what the the amount of mass we're going
to have
well we know that the initial we know
that the initial mass of a sample of
carbon 14 is 741 grams so at t equals
zero our mass is
741.
now what's another interesting t that we
could think about well we know every 5
730 years we lose exactly half of our
mass of carbon 14
every 5 730 years so let's think about
what happens when t is 5730
well we're going to lose half of our
mass
so we're going to multiply this
times one-half
so this is going to be 741
times one-half i'm not even going to
calculate what that is right now and
then let's say we have another
hundred 5730 years take place
so that's going to be and i'm just gonna
write two times five thousand seven
hundred thirty i could calculate it was
going to be ten thousand eleven thousand
four hundred and sixty or something like
that all right but let's just go at two
times five thousand is it ten yeah ten
thousand plus one thousand four hundred
so eleven thousand four hundred plus
sixty yeah so eleven thousand four
hundred sixty but let's just leave it
like this well then it's going to be
this times one half so it's gonna be 741
times one-half
times one-half so we're going to
multiply by one-half again
and so this is the same thing as 741
times one-half
squared
and then let's just think about if we if
we wait another five thousand seven
hundred thirty years so three times five
thousand seven hundred and thirty well
then it's going to be one half times
this so it's going to be 741
this times one half is going to be one
half to the third
power
so you might notice a little bit of a
pattern here however many half-lifes we
have we're going to multiply we're going
to raise one-half to that power and then
multiply it times our initial our
initial mass this is one half-life has
gone by two half-lives we have an
exponent of two three half-lives we
multiply by three sorry we multiply by
one-half three times so what's going to
be a general way to express m of t
well m of t
is going to be our initial value
741 times and you might already be
identifying this as an exponential
function
we're going to multiply times this
number which we could call our common
ratio as many half-lives have passed by
so how do we know how many half-lives
have passed by well we could take t
and we can divide it by the half-life
and try to try to test this out when t
equals zero is going to be one half to
the zero power which is just one and
we're just going to have 741 when t is
equal to 5730 this exponent is going to
be one which we want it to be we're
going to multiply our initial value by
one half once when this exponent is two
times five thousand when t is two times
five thousand seven hundred and thirty
well then the exponent is going to be
two and we're going to multiply by one
half twice it's gonna be one half to the
second power and it's going to work for
everything in between when we are a
fraction of a half-life along we're
gonna get a we're going to get a
non-integer exponent and that 2 will
work out and so this is our function we
are
we are done
we have we have written our function m
that models the mass of carbon 14
remaining t years since the initial
measurement